are being told to stay away I feel like
I've been wanting to make a video about
the virality panic the spreading power
fear fears capacity to hijack our
nervous system there's a great line that
says people don't have ideas ideas have
people our minds can become possessed by
an idea an idea can come to define us or
it can come to destroy us
[Music]
Richard Dawkins wrote in The Selfish
Gene about the rise of means memes are
essentially the new replicators that
have emerged from the primordial soup of
human culture these new replicators
which take the form of ideas these memes
have retained the properties of
organisms they leap from brain to brain
they have infectivity and spreading
power and even though they are not made
of nucleic acid these ideas nonetheless
can and have achieved evolutionary
change at a rate that leaves the old
gene panting far behind these are the
words of James glicks essay what is
and so memes can take hold in the brain
memes again have this infectivity in
spreading power they can hijack our
minds and they can come to define our
lives or destroy our lives now with the
rise of communication technology with
the rise of social media we are living
in a world that more than anything else
traffic's in memes in the attention
economy it has become a race to the
bottom right if it bleeds it leads this
has made our media environment corrosive
one in which a runaway feedback loop
that feeds on fear has taken hold of our
minds has essentially gone viral how
ironic that during a time in which we're
dealing with a real dangerous pathogen
with an actual virus known as the corona
virus what has gone viral
first is fear itself the idea of the
corona virus has inflicted more damage
than the biological virus itself
this is memes gone wild in the worst
sense of the phrase the virality of fear
attached to size and amplifies the power
of social media has taken hold of our
lives has hijacked our well-being and
turned our waking state into one of him
relating anxiousness we are more anxious
we are more depressed than ever before
and it's like the cancer
is spreading we need to understand how
tough this royal leave is for this is
not to say that we don't need to do aid
sobering due diligence and come together
with our scientists and policy makers to
address the problem of a viral outbreak
but what has happened with our mental
states what has happened with the fear
pandemic much more than the biological
pandemic is something that is even more
disconcerting for it has revealed the
fundamental vulnerabilities in our
global system it has revealed the holes
in a system that is broken that is not
serving us it has revealed the holes in
the collective narratives that we need
to have that we need to live by for we
need to live by story we need to live by
narrative lead to live by truthful
fictions by the myths that move us
forward this is what you've all Hari
wrote about in his book sapiens for if
not for our collective mythologies we
cannot come together to address the cut
the challenges before us it's what we've
always done what is needed now in
response to the pathogen of fear to the
epidemic and virality of fear is to
craft the new mythos to craft a new
narrative this goes beyond winning or
losing this is beyond the finite game
it's not about winning or losing it's
about the infinite game that James P
cars' introduces in his book finite and
infinite games we got to keep the game
going we got to come together we got to
craft a mythos we have to attend to our
nervous systems and our collective
planetary anxiety this virus of fear
needs to be attended to we need a
collective and planetary shift that
open-heart surgery of our collective
psyche
now more than ever the psychedelic
revolution for mental health
what is transforming the study of
consciousness the way that the
microscope transformed biology in the
telescope transformed astronomy the new
space is inner space
perhaps this coronavirus will light the
fire under art that is needed to amend
our wounding and to fix our nervous
system for the hive mind is in the state
of fight-or-flight and it serves no one
who can't think rationally we get scared
time to wake up time to shift awareness
time to have the revolution for human
consciousness that everybody has been
talking about time to make a dent in the
universe time to learn to sing the songs
that orchestrate the universe right what
did Flo bear say human speech is but a
cracked kettle in which we tap food
rhythms while we long to make music that
will melt the Stars we must come
together under these new and grand
narratives we must join forces to
address the pathology of fear we will
beat this contagion we will beat this
coronavirus we will beat everything that
came before for his David Deutsch
said we are not the playthings of cosmic
forces we are the users of cosmic forces
but we must awaken to our common ecstasy
we must remember what we forgot let us
come together and let us catalyze that
Martin Luther King called full force
let's turn these passing
into a fiery light let's do the work
after the ecstasy the laundry let us get
to it let us get to it let us get to it
or nothing else will do
[Music]
you